voilà mes chers mes chers collègues
notre traditions
du respect
de leur dit que c'est la politesse des
rois j'ose pas dire nous verrons bien
sûr cet exercice réalisé l'année
prochaine au Sénat
voilà merci merci beaucoup donc cette
séquence est filmée Monsieur le
Directeur du Serena chez absolument ravi
de vous accueillir avec mes collègues
alors comme je vous l'ai dit il se
trouve que cette journée est une journée
un peu compliquée pour les mobilités
n'est ce pas certains peuvent être
carrément immobiles et donc beaucoup de
nos collègues ont dû partir hier donc je
vous prie vraiment
de
nous excuser voilà parce que nous n'y
sommes vraiment mais en tout cas je sais
que vous comprendrez la difficulté de
l'exercice pour nos collègues alors même
que cette audition est extrêmement
importante parce que dans cette
délégation aux collectivités nous
parlons souvent de vous
nous parlons souvent et beaucoup
de la nécessité de d'ingénierie au
service des collectivités parfois de
notre regret de voir que
l'accompagnement qui était réalisé par
l'État notamment
on va dire pour les collectivités de
taille les plus les plus sobre
aujourd'hui cet accompagnement c'est un
peu dévitalisé nous avons au titre de la
délégation un rapport qui a été fait par
mes collègues camaïeu et kerouge sur les
services déconcentrés de l'État et nous
avons beaucoup d'interrogations sur ce
sujet à un moment où la complexité
la complexité des sujets nécessite
vraiment beaucoup d'expertise et les
sujets sont nombreux donc naturellement
nous nous intéressons
à ceux qui accompagnent soit aux agences
soit on va dire au Centre d'études dont
l'expertise est extrêmement reconnue et
donc Monsieur le Directeur votre
expertise et votre accompagnement sont
extrêmement salués
et
nous avons dans la loi 3DS d'ailleurs
beaucoup travaillé pour faciliter le
recours des collectivités à vos services
puisque nous avons permis
que les conditions juridiques de mise à
disposition sont extrêmement simplifiées
puisque aujourd'hui il suffit qu'une
commune en quelque sorte une
collectivité quelle qu'elle soit adhère
au CM1 pour qu'ils des prestations inox
notre collègue Charles Guénet qui peut
pas être là à aussi beaucoup travaillé
sur les sujets d'ingénierie notamment
autour de l'ancté ce qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui ce sont les perspectives du
du serait main sur des sujets
extrêmement nouveaux et surtout on va
dire notre obsession puisque nous sommes
la délégation au collectivités
territoriales dans leur diversité on
sait que votre expertise
est nécessité à la fois par de très
grosses
et de très importantes collectivités
parce que j'ai une expertise technique
dont elles ont besoin parfois de manière
ponctuelle et non pas de manière
récurrente et vous avez cette expertise
de qualité mais aussi par de plus
petites collectivités je pense au sujet
de la sécurité des ponts par exemple ou
que sais-je mais
l'accès
à vos à vos prestations et sans doute
plus difficile pour des petites
collectivités elle ne vous connaissent
pas forcément toutes parce qu'elles
n'ont pas eu ce besoin d'expertise
elles sont un peu perdues dans le maquis
des contributeurs et donc nous notre
obsession c'est l'efficacité de l'action
publique jusqu'au dernier kilomètre et
dans l'efficacité de l'action publique
il y a
line générique qui est accessible pour
tous pour permettre que les
collectivités quelles qu'elles soient ou
qu'elles soient et aussi qu'il peut y
avoir des petites collectivités très
touchées par des sujets techniques on se
rappelle les inondations gravissimes
dans le sud de la France aujourd'hui on
a des vrais sujets sur le littoral avec
la dégradation du trait de côte voilà
donc je crois vous avoir
dit l'essentiel en tout cas l'esprit et
que nous vous remercions d'être là et je
suis sur que mes collègues auront un
certain nombre de questions je les dis
tout à l'heure certains d'entre eux
devront quitter
parce que le train des sénateurs ce
n'est pas qu'il soit lent mais
aujourd'hui il peut être
inaccessible merci Monsieur le Directeur
merci
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les sénatrices
sénateurs je voudrais d'abord vous dire
la grande joie que j'ai de participer à
cette audition c'est vrai que nous avons
depuis maintenant 5 ans vraiment tourné
le cerema vers les collectivités locales
et donc quelque part est audité par la
délégation collectivité donc elle du
Sénat c'est pour nous que une vraie un
vrai aboutissement si j'ose dire et
c'est essentiel alors effectivement le
céréma historiquement c'est les services
techniques de l'ex ministère de
l'Équipement
ceux qui n'étaient pas au niveau
départemental tout ce qui était supra
départemental que l'on a réuni pour
faire un établissement public qui puisse
travailler justement pour l'ensemble de
la communauté nationale
ça nous a pris en vérité 7 ou 8 ans
je tiens à dire parce que souvent quand
on pense des réformes on a l'impression
que ça va se faire tout seul le problème
c'est que derrière on touche des hommes
et des femmes et que tout ça prend un
certain temps donc c'est passé par un
plan de transformation de l'activité
nous avons maintenant recentrer notre
activité sur six domaines les
efficacité énergétique des bâtiments les
mobilités les infrastructures un certain
nombre de sujets en matière de risque et
d'environnement la mer et le littoral et
puisqu'on a appelé les comment dire
l'accompagnement des collectivités
justement sur en gros comment comment
mon territoire va évoluer dans les 30
ans qui viennent avec évidemment un
sujet principal qui est transition
énergétique et surtout et surtout
comment dire adaptation au changement
climatique
nous avons derrière
ça nous a conduit quand même donc
en recentrant nos activités sur ces 6
domaines pour vous donner une idée à
supprimer l'activité sur deux secteurs
sur trois donc vraiment une
restructuration interne très profonde
qui a touché à peu près la moitié des
2500 agents de du céréma 350
suppressions de poste 750 postes que
l'on a qualifié du dounon de
substantiellement modifié pour dire
qu'en fait le contenu du job changé à
plus de la moitié voilà donc une
restructuration très profonde mais qui
était absolument nécessaire et je dois
dire d'ailleurs sur ce plan là que
justement la transformation c'est aussi
à un moment
de voir que les choses qui sont
accumulées depuis 40 ans ça nécessite un
grand coup de ménage et voilà donc on
l'a fait on est très content de l'avoir
fait derrière évidemment on a mis en
place une démarche qualité unifiée
l'échelle de l'établissement ça peut
paraître bizarre mais toutes ces
structures n'étaient pas agréé donc
aujourd'hui tout le monde est isolé 9000
ans etc etc évidemment à bâtir un projet
stratégique à bâtir un contrat
d'objectif avec l'État et puis
effectivement ce qu'on appelle notre
plan d'affaires qui est vraiment une
déclinaison des objectifs du contrat
d'objectif pour aller justement vers les
collectivités vers les entreprises
puisque initialement si vous voulez en
2017 le cereman travaillait quasiment
que pour l'État ce qui quand on est sur
les sujets les domaines que je viens
d'énumérer et quand même un peu bizarre
puisque au 2/3 ce sont des sujets de
compétences collectivités donc on a
vraiment travaillé sur ce sujet là et
aujourd'hui on a un gros quart de
l'activité qui est fait pour les
collectivités locales soit fait et
facturer au collectivités locales soit
fait en développement méthodologique et
mis à disposition effectivement des
collectivités alors effectivement une
fois qu'on avait
restructuré la boutique on avait quand
même un sujet c'est que la gouvernance
de l'établissement était encore
quasiment totalement étatique et que
effectivement le travail avec les
collectivités restaient quand même assez
compliqué une excellente
article qui a été effectivement proposé
par le Sénat dans la loi 3DS qui a
permis aux collectivités d'adhérer au
cerema et en adhérent au céréma d'une
part évidemment elles élissent des
représentants dans la gouvernance et ça
c'est pas négligeable ça veut dire que
la gouvernance du céréma va être
majoritairement fait par des
collectivités et puis effectivement ça
permet d'agir pour elle selon la règle
de inaos alors la date de cette audition
est particulièrement bien vue parce que
il se trouve que le conseil
d'administration de mardi donc il y a
deux jours à valider effectivement
la première liste des collectivités
adhérentes il y en a 634 donc 14 régions
70 départements 272 groupements de
communes et 278 communes et donc je
crois que on peut dire que c'est
effectivement un grand succès et que ça
va nous permettre évidemment de
démultiplier très fortement l'adhésion
aux travaux pour les collectivités parce
que on se dit comme ça que les
collectivités qui ont fait le choix
d'adhérer au céréma c'est pas gratuit en
plus c'est quand même qu'elles attendent
des choses du céréma et alors
effectivement ça nous honore beaucoup
mais surtout lorsqu'on se dit c'est que
ça nous oblige beaucoup et donc on a
devant nous une période assez forte
effectivement de travail pour les pour
les collectivités peut-être un point
avant de venir un peu sur les sujets du
futur
un point sur l'intégration du serema
dans l'écosystème parce que vous l'avez
dit à la fois il y a des manques sur le
terrain j'y reviendrai et à la fois il y
a tout un foisonnement où finalement
plus personne ne sait comment se retenir
nous ce que nous avons essayé
effectivement c'est de nous intégrer
dans l'écosystème à travers d'une part
des conventions des partenariats avec un
petit peu nos homologues nos
établissements homologues je pense à
l'IGN au bergm à l'inerises etc donc on
essaye d'avoir des relations de
partenariat assez fortes qui nous
permettent de dire quand on nous pose
une question qu'elle est plutôt du
ressort du BRGM dit bah attendez voilà
voilà mon collègue donc on est on essaye
vraiment de faire ça évidemment un
travail avec la NCT j'imagine qu'il y
aura des questions sur le sujet nous
avons passé en application de la loi
d'ailleurs une convention avec la NCT
qui nous permet d'intervenir d'une part
sur ce qu'ils appellent les programmes
nationaux territorialisés je pense à
cœur de ville petite ville de demain etc
et sur le sur mesure avec une logique
que l'on a mis en place qui est celle du
freemium c'est aussi une la possibilité
souhaite être accompagnée le céréma
l'accompagne quelques jours de façon
gratuite au départ et puis si elle
souhaite aller plus loin à ce moment-là
le serema facture une partie de la
prestation et la NCT on paye une partie
c'est quelque chose qui a plutôt pas mal
marché on a sur les deux dernières
années accompagnées 329 communes pour un
montant de un peu plus de 5 millions
d'euros dont 2,3 de cofinancement le
cerema est aujourd'hui je crois pouvoir
le dire la NCT elle-même le dit
probablement le partenaire de le plus
actif justement effectivement dans les
deux communes même si et vous avez tout
à fait raison
aujourd'hui il y a encore énormément de
demandes auxquelles on n'arrive pas à
satisfaire et c'est vrai vous vous le
disiez madame ma présidente une espèce
de maquis des organismes dans lequel les
élus savent plus trop à qui s'adresser
je vais me permettre sur ce plan là
petite incidence il se trouve moi j'ai
commencé il y a plus de 35 ans dans une
DDE je m'occupais d'un service
collectivité locale et
à l'époque effectivement il y avait dans
les DDE dans les DDA des services des
gens qui donc métier étaient d'aider les
collectivités particulièrement les plus
petites bien sûr et c'est vrai que en
supprimant tout cela au fur et à mesure
des réformes successives de l'État on a
laissé je crois les élus sans
interlocuteur technique alors bien sûr
ils ont comme interlocuteur le préfet
enfin d'abord le préfet il a de 24
heures dans sa journée et puis surtout
il y a plus d'interlocuteurs techniques
et c'est vrai que nous nous poussons
beaucoup pour qu'il se recréer quelque
chose au niveau départemental entre nous
à apprendre cinq équivalentes en plein
ou 10 équivalent en plein dans chaque
des DT c'est pas forcément la mort c'est
pas forcément si compliqué que ça à
faire et à partir du moment où il y a
une société qui est capable de
chapeauter l'ensemble il y a peut-être
quelque chose à recréer qui est pas
forcément hors de portée si j'ose dire
parce que évidemment c'est c'est la
question en tout cas pour nous qui
assureront ce qu'on peut appeler
l'expertise de deuxième niveau nous on a
on a regroupé les organismes qui
justement conseillaient ces cellules
j'ai en gros comment ça se passait avant
une collectivité il y a 30 ans quand
elle avait un problème elle avait son
subdivisionnaire qui était à côté si
c'était trop compliqué pour le
subdivisionnaire il a plein de siège de
la DDE et puis si c'était trop compliqué
pour le siège de la DDE on appelait les
CT les services techniques etc tout ce
qu'on a fusionné dans le céréma et c'est
vrai que pour nous c'est Rema avoir des
relais techniques en département serait
quelque chose effectivement d'assez fort
alors évidemment ne nous trompons pas on
nous sommes présents sur le territoire
nous avons 23 villes d'implantation en
gros c'est la maille des anciennes
régions pour pour simplifier mais en
même temps même en étant présent dans
l'ensemble des territoires on voit que
ce dernier kilomètre comme vous le
disiez on a quand même des difficultés à
le faire et donc il y a probablement
quelque chose à faire et je tiens
vraiment à le redire qui est pas
forcément si compliqué que ça
globalement effectivement si je reviens
sur sur le fond maintenant et sur les
questions qui restent à venir et à mon
avis je justifie encore plus d'essayer
de recréer quelque chose au niveau
départemental c'est qu'on a avec la
transition écologique à mener et
l'adaptation au changement climatique
des chantiers absolument énormes
derrière nous alors entendons-nous bien
on entend tous dans les médias des
prophètes qui expliquent qu'on va tous
mourir nous au cerema nous avons le
changement climatique heureux
ah bah ça c'est vrai un jour un jour
on a on a alors ça paraît bizarre mais
on est on s'est donné comme règles
d'avoir le changement climatique
optimiste et d'ailleurs quand je vois le
rapport du GIEC qui est sorti lundi nous
on a été très content parce que
finalement le GIEC disque nous nous
disons depuis trois ou quatre ans que
dire mais des solutions il y en a faut
pas on va pas on va pas tous mourir
demain à cause du changement climatique
par contre ce qui est vrai c'est des
vraies ruptures c'est des changements
majeurs en même temps on a 20 ans 30 ans
pour le faire donc évidemment si on
attend 20 ans pour commencer ça se
passera très très mal d'ailleurs en
réalité quand vous regardez dans
l'histoire de l'humanité des ruptures il
y en a eu beaucoup elles se sont
toujours mal passées parce qu'on les a
pas anticipés donc voilà donc nous ce
que nous pensons profondément
effectivement c'est qu'il faut arriver à
changer le mode de fonctionnement avec
plus de sobriété plus de résilience plus
d'inclutés plus de créativité mais que
aujourd'hui quelque part effectivement
en tout cas dans les secteurs dont on
s'occupe que j'ai cité tout à l'heure
nous pensions effectivement que chacun
des ces secteurs est impacté mais que
chacun de ces secteurs il y a des
solutions ça passe par quoi bah ça passe
évidemment par un très gros effort de
formation à la fois des élus et des
techniciens ça passe évidemment par se
doter d'un référentiel de durabilité
type odd agenda 2030 d'inclure les
parties prenantes de travailler sur les
imaginaires de mettre en place un
système de pilotage bref c'est sûr que
le chantier est assez énorme parce qu'il
faut toucher à tout en même temps voilà
sur chaque sujet individuellement les
solutions existent évidemment grosse
acculturation nécessaire des élus
ministre travaille d'ailleurs sur ce
type de choses et ça nous semble
essentiel et puis bien sûr et je
m'arrêterai là des besoins financiers
qui peuvent être assez importants en
même temps quand on voit les
conséquences financières en matière de
changement climatique de toute façon on
n'a pas le choix voilà je vais peut-être
m'arrêter là pour plutôt répondre à vos
questions parce que sinon je pourrais
parler pendant
ce sujet là merci beaucoup monsieur le
monsieur le directeur donc juste en écho
avant de passer la parole à mes
collègues qui ont de nombreuses
questions je crois que vous avez évoqué
l'ensemble des sujets c'est à dire nous
sommes aujourd'hui mais je crois que
l'histoire de l'humanité les fêtes de ça
dans une période de rupture qu'il faut
préparer et anticiper et avoir
l'écologie triste ou mortifère je pense
que ça n'est ni notre volonté ni notre
intérêt ensuite je pense qu'on a vous
l'avez un peu évoqué ce sujet de la
dispersion de ligne générique et de la
difficulté à voir avoir accès aux choses
et vous le savez puisque nous avons eu
l'occasion d'en parler dans la réflexion
que nous conduisons avec Mathieu
d'Arnaud et le président sous la
présidence de François Naël buffet qui
est président de la commission des lois
mais surtout à l'initiative du président
l'archet dans cette réflexion
transpartisale son efficacité de
l'action vous le savez on a eu
l'occasion d'échanger nous avons une
interrogation mais nous
sommes en réflexion on va dire
extrêmement ouverte nous voulons
défendre l'accès à l'ingénierie pour
l'ensemble des collectivités et nous
nous interrogeons vous vous l'avez
évoqué sur la manière dont les
différentes agences fonctionnent
ensemble est-ce que c'est agile est-ce
que c'est souple il s'agit pas d'in des
je sais votre agilité la manière dont
vous savez vous adapter à intervenir etc
mais est-ce que des directions
régionales sont pertinentes comme on est
dans des grandes régions comment le
préfet ou le sous-préfet qui peut être
sollicité parfois parce qu'il identifie
il est détecteur de sujets souvent le
sous-préfet ou le préfet comment il vous
actionne comment les différentes agences
sont coordonnées voilà les questions
générales et je vais vite passer la
parole à mes collègues Jean-Michel
Houlgate puis Hervé gilet
merci merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur le Directeur le fond vert donc
de 2 milliards d'euros donc c'est des
financements conséquent qui arrive
maintenant donc les enveloppes sont
désormais notifiées dans dans les
départements donc les appels d'une
certaine façon un projet sont lancés et
on voit très bien que à travers les
thématiques et les axes qui couvrent le
fond vert et bien le cerema peut-être
directement concerné en ce qui concerne
un apport un ingénierie aux
collectivités territoriales si on veut
que que
ces fonds soient mobilisées assez
rapidement il faut que les collectivités
puissent déposer les projets le plus
rapidement possible donc est-ce que vous
êtes d'une certaine façon parée
notamment sur des sujets alors si il y a
des sujets qui sont peut-être des
opérations un peu un peu itérative qui
demande pas une très grande complexité
quoi que quoi que je pense notamment à
la rénovation thermique des bâtiments
mais il y a des opérations qui sont un
peu plus complexes comme prévenir les
risques d'incendie de forêt comme
prévenir le recul du du trait de côte ou
tout ce qui concerne bien évidemment les
inondations à la fois le volet papilles
et j'ai Mappy donc comment vous abordez
vous au niveau du serema c'est
accompagnement qui va être nécessaire
pour permettre justement aux
collectivités de façon la plus
efficiente possible de pouvoir mobiliser
le fond vert
merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur
je vais peut-être essayer de vous
bousculer un peu
sur sur l'approche et la mise en oeuvre
justement de l'ingénierie territoriale
en fait quand on regarde bien c'est
toujours compliqué un peu la saisine les
délais sont parfois un peu longs la
réactivité n'est pas toujours au
rendez-vous c'est parfois un peu
complexe et en fait on manque toujours
d'un guichet
d'entrée qui soit réellement efficace
alors là NCT bien sûr est questionnée
par rapport à ça mais moi j'ai toujours
le sentiment que l'organisation
territoriale peut parfois être à même de
répondre à beaucoup de questions et en
l'occurrence
s'appuyer sur les syndicats mixtes de
territoire porteur parfois des contrats
de pays etc qui sont eux-mêmes déjà des
collectivités en amont et en
accompagnement des communautés de
communes et des communes sur un certain
niveau d'ingénierie ça devrait être une
stratégie assez payante en fait parce
que il s'agit d'organiser l'ingénierie
territoriale et si possible à l'échelle
d'un projet de territoire et en
subsidiarité de voir comment avec les
CDC avec les communes on vient aussi
compléter la boîte aux outils si vous me
permettez cette expression or on ne voit
pas trop là-dessus c'est pas forcément
quelque part une stratégie d'autre part
d'aller chercher véritablement la
coopération territoriale et de mettre en
évidence votre offre de service dans
l'idéal essayons de rêver ça serait bien
que l'inct est la même stratégie
justement de mise en lisibilité et si on
rêvait encore un peu plus loin cette
stratégie d'État elle mérite en plus
d'être confortée ce qui n'est pas encore
suffisamment le cas avec des conventions
avec les collectivités territoriales les
régions et les départements pour qu'on
fonctionner en bourse de compétences
beaucoup plus lisible aujourd'hui en
fonction de la nature des projets
voilà un peu mes espoirs qu'en
pensez-vous est-ce que vous partagez mon
avis
c'est un mot qu'on aime beaucoup au
céréma
je suis arrivé
début 2018 après une très graphise
qui a connu l'organisme puisque suite au
vote du quinquennat 2017-2022 qui
réduisait de 500 et TP les effectifs du
CRMA directeur et démissionné le
président avait démissionné les salariés
manifestaient dans la rue enfin voilà et
effectivement ça a été mon leitmotiv du
premier jour où je suis arrivé jusqu'à
maintenant et ça continue justement de
dire bah non on se retrousse les manches
il y a de l'espoir il y a pas de sujet
etc et aujourd'hui les agents du céréma
d'ailleurs commencent à dire tiens
finalement il avait peut-être pas tort
alors sur sur le fond vert effectivement
on a été très largement très largement
concerné puisqu'en gros je vois sur les
C14
thématiques on est concernés par 11 donc
évidemment ça va assez loin et c'est
vrai que
clairement
on sent que la demande est
particulièrement forte et
particulièrement effectivement au niveau
des territoires alors êtes-vous prêts en
fait la question de fond elle est
aujourd'hui c'est Réma c'est à peu près
2000 experts entre ingénieurs et
technicien si si j'enlève les fonctions
support etc
et que évidemment
on ne peut pas tout faire alors pour
deux raisons la première c'est que à
2000 on peut pas faire le travail pour
lequel il faudrait 6000 personnes pour
le faire et puis la deuxième surtout
c'est que j'ai expliqué on le Salama a
été créé en regroupant plutôt les
organismes de deuxième niveau donc notre
enjeu c'est plutôt de trouver des relais
que l'on puisse former que l'on puisse
accompagner et qui effectivement puisse
se déployer sur le terrain pour ça que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
l'ingénierie publique dans le dans les
DDE il y a une trentaine d'années parce
que pour avoir commencé une carrière
comme ça quand même ça fonctionnait quoi
je veux dire l'élu que ce soit du d'une
grosse collectivité d'une petite
collectivité il avait en face de lui
déjà un minimum de compétences
techniques et c'est vrai que le sujet de
Fond aujourd'hui en ce qui concerne les
DDT alors ils vont certains vont
sûrement m'en vouloir mais la vérité
c'est qu'il y a plus de compétences
techniques et à partir du moment où il y
a plus de compétences techniques c'est
évidemment difficile d'accompagner les
collectivités par contre il y a de la
compétence administrative etc mais voilà
donc nous effectivement nous appelons
très fortement de nos vœux
recréation de compétences techniques sur
le terrain alors nous on peut les former
les animer leur donner des méthodes en
gros ce que ce que faisait avant le
réseau technique vis-à-vis des DDE
est-ce qu'il répond
monsieur gilet à votre question c'est
exactement ça c'était oui bien sûr
est-ce que vous êtes prêt à travailler
avec les syndicats territoire et tout
évidemment c'est tout le sens de la
réforme statutaire qu'on a fait et de
l'adhésion des collectivités d'ailleurs
je crois que dans la salle il y a
quasiment que des territoires où les
départements sont adhérents
on regardait là voilà donc c'est non
mais des départements mais surtout des
collectivités c'est encore une fois
comme je le disais 200 272 interco il
faudra aller plus loin c'est le départ
et évidemment l'idée c'est bien celle-là
c'est bien de s'appuyer effectivement
sur les collectivités de les aider à
monter en compétences sur le plan
technique pour effectivement arriver à
faire la réponse est vraiment mille fois
oui quoi
après faut y arriver alors oui juste
après est-ce que c'est ce que vous
faites aujourd'hui non non pour plus non
mais pour plusieurs raisons la première
c'est que en réalité le ceremat tel que
je viens de vous le décrire il
fonctionne comme ça depuis 2022 parce
qu'on a quand même mis quatre ans à
restructurer la boutique et quand vous
devez changer tous les missions les
personnes les machins etc alors on a mis
quatre ans on estime nous fonctionnait à
peu près correctement depuis depuis un
an
non aussi parce que il y a des questions
de de moyens à la fois sur l'évolution
des compétences des personnels du céréma
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
des gens qui sont capables d'aller
accompagner des collectivités dans
l'esprit tel que je viens de le décrire
on en a
allez 120 150 évidemment il faut qu'on
en ait beaucoup plus mais rassurez-vous
il y a quatre ans on en avait 10 donc
voilà on l'a aussi on a une progression
assez forte et puis du coup je vais
quand même me permettre le petit couplet
revendicatif à un moment si on augmente
pas les effectifs on aura aussi du mal
parce que la France est grande parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de collectivités ça
c'était pour le PLF voilà
[Rires]
[Musique]
juste un point là-dessus en fait parce
que en fait la demande du Serena dans le
PLF elle n'est pas de demander les
moyens supplémentaires à l'état parce
qu'en vérité quand on va voir des
collectivités elle nous disent mais
attendez nous si vous nous fournissez le
service on est prêt à payer un peu donc
notre sujet il est surtout sur le
plafond d'emploi plus que sur le plus
que sur les dotations
très bien la parole de notre collègue ça
va être rapide parce que
de l'Indre
vous avez déjà en fait en partie répondu
au à mes questions via la question posée
par mon collègue Hervé sur cette
collaboration on va dire avec les
territoires et les collectivités
territoriales en effet on peut être
nostalgique de la thésat et de tous ces
services qui étaient rendus par les
services de l'État aux collectivité et
il existe les départements ce sont
souvent fait le relais après de ces de
ce manque de service dans nos communes
et départements ou région et donc il y a
eu des créations comme nous dans le
département de l'Inde de l'agence
technique départementale qui ont pas
forcément toutes les missions que que
vous avez aujourd'hui puisque par
exemple chez nous c'est la voirie les
ouvrages d'art voilà qui apportent
qui apporte aussi de de des compétences
techniques donc ma question c'était
cette relation que vous pouvez avoir
dans les territoires parce que vous
amenez aussi vous beaucoup plus de
thématiques mais vous avez en partie
répondu puisque en effet il faut essayer
de travailler davantage ensemble et de
voir comment on peut faire avancer ces
agences et aussi votre vomissions vous
avez je voulais vous demander en effet à
combien vous estimiez parce que je me
doutais que l'aspect entre guillemets
budgétaire à combien vous estimiez vos
besoins en termes de personnel parce que
tout ça demande évidemment des hommes et
des femmes pour répondre aux demandes
des collectivités et éventuellement vous
avez déjà beaucoup de missions mais ce
que au bout de c'est pas très très long
comme comme retour d'expérience mais
est-ce que vous voyez des missions que
qui vous seraient demandées aujourd'hui
et qui ne sont pas dans votre dans votre
panier de compétences et dernière
question
est-ce que agence la NCT et vous ne
pourriez pas faire qu'un jour
voilà pour
je vous en prie Monsieur
alors sur sur je vous remercie vraiment
de la question parce que j'ai passé un
peu vite sur le lien avec les agences
départementales les agences d'urbanisme
etc qui nous semblent absolument
essentiels quand je dis avant il y avait
les DT il y avait les DDE les DDA etc le
contexte a complètement changé et c'est
vrai que pour nous notre sujet c'est
vraiment de trouver des partenaires
localement qui ont pu se marcher et les
agences départementales au premier lieu
évidemment sont naturellement nos
partenaires donc on a beaucoup de
discussions avec l'association des
directeurs d'agences départementales je
l'espère dans la gouvernance du céréma
il va y avoir une agence départementale
qui rentre au conseil d'administration
en train d'essayer de faire en sorte que
que ça soit le cas voilà l'idée c'est
vraiment de dire de recréer si vous
voulez ce lien entre l'organisme
d'expertise et puis ils organismes qui
sont sur le terrain donc je rejoins tout
à fait il en est évidemment de même pour
les agences d'urbanisme voilà en tout
cas nous tel que nous voyons le rôle du
Serena ce qu'on essaye d'expliquer à
tout le monde c'est qu'on le voit
vraiment en complémentarité
avec une vraie logique de subsidiarité
on veut pas aller concurrencer l'agence
d'urbanisme la chance départementale on
vient derrière si ça marche sans nous
bah tant mieux tant mieux voilà donc ça
c'est pour nous assez majeur alors sur
l'émission supplémentaire
et sur les besoins
avec nos missions actuelles sur les
besoins on est vraiment en train
d'essayer d'évaluer ça de façon précise
en vrai on arrive à avoir qu'on a besoin
de en gros 400 et TP supplémentaires
mais qu'on est quand même capable d'enro
déployer un certain nombre parce que
certes on a beaucoup secoué le cocotier
mais après il y a quand même toujours un
peu et finalement on est sur un ordre de
grandeur de 200 et TP supplémentaires
sur trois quatre ans donc c'est pas non
plus c'est pas non plus si énorme que ça
sur les missions supplémentaires on
réfléchi effectivement un certain nombre
de sujets je pense notamment au sujet
ferroviaire qu'on a quasiment totalement
abandonné parce qu'à ce moment il a
fallu faire des choix donc effectivement
la question peut se poser il y a des
sujets sur lesquels il faut qu'on monte
en compétences et en intensité je pense
notamment toutes les questions de
participation du public on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui elles sont quand même au
cœur finalement de tous les projets donc
on a probablement beaucoup à travailler
la suite voilà donc on a quelques
quelques sujets ça fait partie de nos
réflexions pour notre prochain contrat
d'objectifs
ça nous change parce que on a passé les
4 dernières années en supprimé donc
réfléchir à ce que pourrait être des
missions s'il vous plaît imaginez bien
même quand en terme d'animation des
équipes évidemment c'est plus la même
chose et puis sur la question
est-ce que il faudrait fusionner ou pas
la même réponse que j'ai fait l'autre
jour et évidemment que Serena a NCT
probablement ADEME d'ailleurs évidemment
si aujourd'hui on construisait les
choses on ferait un seul organisme il y
a pas il y a personne se poserait la
question de faire des organismes séparés
et donc évidemment que la question dire
c'est intelligente fusionner elle est
normale légitime etc alors après
moi la vision que j'en ai c'est que pour
créer le céréma donc on a mis 8 ans ce
qui fonctionne depuis 2022 vraiment bien
enfin été créé au 1er janvier 2014 donc
pour arriver à faire fonctionner le truc
on a peut-être perdu un peu de temps ok
on aurait pu ne mettre que 6 ans mais
c'était quand même assez simple de faire
le CRMA c'est elle comprenait des
organismes qui venaient toutes du même
ministère avec la même culture avec des
personnels qui avaient les mêmes statuts
et donc voilà alors nous ce qu'on se dit
c'est que si on se lance dans une fusion
à NCT céréma on va encore perdre 50 ans
quoi parce que pendant ce temps-là les
gens ne penseront plus qu'à ça etc donc
je compense c'est que ce qui est en tout
cas
en termes de méthode ce qui nous semble
probablement plus intelligents plus
intelligent je sais pas mais en tout cas
plus efficace c'est vraiment de dire
rapprochons les organismes par exemple
un comité un comité de direction commun
tous les mois des choses de ce type là
une stratégie commune faisons-le
progressivement en laissant les
organismes tels qu'ils sont et en les
rapprochant et quand les gens seront
suffisamment proches etc à ce moment là
on pourra faire la fusion parce qu'elle
sera simple parce que si on part
aujourd'hui sur la fusion ma crainte
très sincèrement c'est qu'en fait le
travail s'arrête quoi parce qu'à ce
moment-là les gens ne pensent plus qu'à
ça voilà mais mais la question elle est
évidemment 100% légitime enfin
notre collègue de Chantal d'Eure-et-Loir
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Directeur toujours sur le même thème
parce que vous avez une expertise qui
est reconnue vous êtes bien
identifié par les grandes collectivités
par contre les élus
des petites communes en particulier se
perdent dans le maquis des agences
donc est-ce que vous travaillez déjà
mais bon c'est ce que vous venez de dire
un petit peu est-ce que vous travaillez
déjà la rationalisation de l'offre et en
particulier à la mise en place d'agences
départementales pour que vous soyez plus
visible et mieux identifié et
satisfaire l'accompagnement des
collectivités
tout à fait sur l'impression de Maki des
agences
l'idée de la création de la NCT c'était
justement l'idée de simplifier tout ça
non nous ce que nous pensons c'est qu'il
faut effectivement créer au niveau
départemental quelque chose qu'on
pourrait appeler guichet unique mais je
méfie des noms parce que c'est un
guichet unique à l'entrée parce que si
on veut faire une voilà mais donc
effectivement qui est dans chaque
département
un minimum de gens qui soient chargés de
ça de savoir où sont les offres etc et
quand un élu petite commune ou une
grande commune d'ailleurs vient de voir
et dit bah voilà ah bah oui ça vous
pouvez c'est Monsieur machin madame truc
voilà le téléphone etc ça je crois que
c'est indispensable et sincèrement c'est
pas énorme enfin encore une fois que je
vois que tout à l'heure bête quatre ou
cinq personnes créer des cellules de 5
personnes dans chaque département ça
fait 500 et TP
fonctionnaire de l'État c'est 2 millions
non je n'ai pas capable de dégager donc
voilà je vous rejoins tout à fait je
pense que ça c'est faisable et c'est pas
objectif effectivement ça améliorerait
assez largement les choses sans rentrer
dans des logiques de fusion de machin
qui vont qui vont effectivement tout
bloquer nous ce qu'on a fait pour les
adhérents c'est que on a on est en train
de mettre en place un référent pour
chaque adhérence c'est-à-dire que chaque
adhérent aura un interlocuteur avec le
numéro de portable etc au céréma et dès
qu'il y a un sujet il appelle son
référent et c'est le référen ce qu'on a
aussi même en interne Serena c'est
tellement large un maquis mais là c'est
le référent qui a bah non bah là ça
c'est Monsieur machin je vous l'appelle
je vous mets en contact etc etc donc ça
moi je crois énormément à ça c'est pas
très compliqué à mettre en place c'est
pas très coûteux en équivalent temps
plein et en fait ça réglera 90%
du sujet
en complément Monsieur le Directeur moi
comme nous tous nous sommes sensibles à
votre souci d'efficacité et d'être
d'abord efficace avant d'être en
mouvement perpétuel
d'organisation de réorganisation nous
avons les uns et les autres que les
mouvements d'organisation nous l'avons
vu avec les recompositions d'intercaux
etc c'est un temps qui est compliqué qui
parfois ne permet pas
d'être et en même temps si je puis dire
la vie est un éternel changement et
qu'il convient de s'adapter vous l'avez
dit c'est compliqué pour les personnels
mais je crois que les choses sont là et
si on reprend un peu le fil de
l'histoire à un moment l'état
a décidé
de en tout cas à alléger
c'est ce que j'appelle ces directions
territoriales et ses représentations qui
sont les préfectures les
sous-préfectures donc on a vidé de
compétences et de services et on a pensé
à leur sans doute que ça coûterait
peut-être moins cher mais que en ayant
des agents on serait plus agile ce
serait plus souple etc moi je crois
beaucoup au fait que à un moment
déstructures
extérieures à une structure monolithique
de de l'État soit efficace mais il me
semble qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes un peu
au bout de l'exercice et qu'il y a parce
que les compétences qui ont été
transférées aux collectivités
nécessitent non plus seulement une
générique mais de l'expertise et que je
ne crois pas que chaque département
chaque interco va voir en son sein une
expertise pérenne sur le ferroviaire sur
le trait de côte voilà on n'a pas besoin
de ce niveau
et que donc
des des structures qui ont ces
expertises qui en plus s'enrichissent du
fait que elles ont été exercées dans des
contextes différents et que je pense que
la capacité à bien apprécier une
situation vient aussi des expériences
successives on a une plus grande de
maîtrise mais que quand vous parlez de
guichet unique moi je suis d'accord mais
j'ai un raisonnement très simple le
guigini pour moi c'est le sous-préfet ou
la préfecture parce qu'à un moment
Monsieur le Directeur et nous c'est
notre sujet
il y a un état
qui a fixé des obligations à des élus je
pense à la submersion marine je pense à
la préservation de l'environnement ou
que sais-je et qu'il faut que l'État
s'assure que les collectivités
s'inscrivent dans ces objectifs mais
surtout
que l'État accompagne les collectivités
pour permettre de réaliser ça et moi je
pense encore une fois comme je l'éditeur
que le détecteur de sujets et de besoin
d'expertise c'est le sous-préfet ou le
préfet ne croyez-vous pas que c'est lui
qui doit pouvoir coordonner et assembler
les structures qu'elles soient encore en
agence ou pas ça me semble être plus
efficace
plus simple et en même temps peut-être
prendre en compte le fait que le
changement c'est nécessaire mais c'est
compliqué puis dernière question que
j'aurais Monsieur le Directeur est-ce
que
l'adhésion des collectivités
dont vous nous avez parlé je vous
félicite de leur nom ça veut dire qu'il
y a une reconnaissance
de votre expertise et avoir besoin
est-ce qu'il y a une répartition
géographique régulière ou est-ce que ce
sont des territoires où vous avez déjà
identifié des sujets qui sont vraiment
les vôtres je pense au trait de côte je
pense à dos à d'autres risques voilà
Monsieur le Directeur
merci beaucoup
identifié par par le Sénat suite à
l'effondrement du pont Morandi donc
c'est la mission d'information en 2019
sur la sécurité des ponts on avait
identifié qu'il y avait à peu près 25000
ponts en France qui présentaient et qui
présentaient des risques et pour lequel
d'ailleurs il y avait un problème
souvent de méconnaissance de la part des
collectivités parce qu'au moment des
transferts de compétences il y a pas eu
le transfert des dossiers de recollement
si on peut dire d'une certaine façon et
qu'elle est dossiers de de réalisation
d'ouvrages qui sont dans la nature donc
difficile à
comment dirais-je à identifier donc pour
savoir un peu où est-ce que vous en
étiez vous particulièrement sur ce point
sur ce point de la sécurisation des cons
et le Centre national des ponts de
secours qui est un bien précieux
merci beaucoup
je crois qu'en fait
effectivement il y a tout un continuum
entre
l'ingénierie de base et l'expertise la
plus pointue
aujourd'hui
parle d'ingénierie de base je veux dire
sur des sujets basiques et traditionnels
je vais pas refaire la place de l'église
la plupart des collectivités
ont d'une façon ou d'une autre ou via
leur interco machin mais on grosso modo
les compétences pour arriver à bâtir un
projet pour refaire la place de l'église
j'ai beaucoup vécu personnellement dans
le monde voilà
la difficulté évidemment
elle est que
on est sur des sujets qui sont de plus
en plus complexes
projetées ce que sera ma collectivité
dans 30 ans avec le changement
climatique et qu'est-ce qu'il faut que
je fasse pour m'y préparer c'est
évidemment un petit peu plus compliqué
clairement en ce qui concerne
l'expertise
vous l'avez tout à fait dit
tout le monde ne peut pas se la payer
vous savez
je vais parler des ponts sur les ponts
bon très clairement l'expert français
sur les ponts c'est le céréma on a 300
personnes au céréma sur le sujet face
dans ces 300 personnes j'ai une
vingtaine d'experts de niveau experts
international voilà une vingtaine ça
fait un pas région quoi en gros allez
demi pas pression donc en vérité
effectivement il y a de toute façon
cette nécessité à un moment de
mutualiser un certain nombre
d'expertises parce que le pays ne peut
pas en plus ça n'aurait pas de sens de
de sans payer plus ça veut dire derrière
qu'il faut organiser effectivement tout
tout un quantum entre deux de
l'expertise au niveau national de
l'expertise dans les collectivités de
l'expertise privée aussi et nous on a
essayé de beaucoup travailler avec les
syndicats de des ingénistes privés avec
une convention avec Syntec Ingénierie et
d'ailleurs il y a un représentant de
syntheque ingénierie qui est dans le
conseil d'administration du SER Rema une
convention avec synov qui regroupe
plutôt les plus petits bureaux d'études
et notamment on travaille avec eux sur
la formation des bureaux d'études parce
que en fait on voit bien que le sujet de
fond il est sur les compétences et donc
nous on estime qu'on a ce rôle de
diffusion des compétences de formation
etc
je reviendrai après sur le guichet
unique mais je pense qu'on a aussi ce
sujet là sur sur les administrations
peut-être un petit mot sur les ponts
alors le programme pont effectivement
est en train de programme pont 1 pardon
et est en train de se terminer nous
aurons
expertisé entre 45 et 50 000 ponts sur
des collectivités de petites tailles
puisque on avait réservé le programme
aux collectivités dites excatesat ça
fait 28 000 communes à peu près
[Musique]
on a touché 12000
cela est dit pour la petite histoire
pour arriver à en toucher 12000 on a mis
6 mois la missimoine parce que en
réalité évidemment la petite commune de
500 habitants au mieux il y a un
secrétaire de mairie une demi-journée
par semaine et c'était entièrement
gratuit pour les communes simplement
avant d'aller expertiser leurs ponts
fallait quand même qu'on ait au minimum
un mail de quelqu'un de la mairie qui
nous disent oui je suis d'accord venez
expertiser mon pot on a mis 6 mois on en
a touché 12000 sur
le vivier c'était 20000 donc bon c'est
pas mal mais du coup
ça amène à faire un programme pont 2
puisque justement vous avez eu
l'extrême délicatesse de voter des
crédits supplémentaires on va les faire
2022 que le ministère nous a redélégué
donc pour 50 millions d'euros dont une
première une partie lors de 10 millions
d'euros sera fait pour faire un
programme pont 2 pour toucher toutes les
collectivité qui n'ont pas pu répondre
etc donc l'idée c'est de s'approcher des
18-20 000 pour avoir la totalité j'ai au
bout de deux programmes ceux qui
n'auront pas voulu c'est leur choix
voilà et puis et puis derrière
évidemment nous travaillons à la mise en
place d'un programme de subventionnement
de travaux pour les communes en ciblant
évidemment sur les
ouvrages qui sont les plus impactés pour
pour la petite histoire sur le programme
programme pour un là sur les 45 et
quelques milles en gros vous en avez 25%
qui nécessitent des travaux et dans ces
25%, il y a 8% enfin pas 8% de 25 il y a
8% de d'ouvrages sur lesquels il a fallu
prendre des mesures immédiates fermeture
de l'ouvrage diminution du tonnage etc
donc voilà donc il y a un vrai sujet
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'évidemment
c'est pas non plus des ouvrages
il y en a quelques-uns mais la grande
majorité c'est des ouvrages entre
guillemets petite taille on est sur un
montant moyen de travaux de réparation
de remise au nord qui est de l'ordre de
150 000 € par ouvrage ce qui est quand
même déjà beaucoup pour une petite
commune voilà mais donc on est sur des
donc on est en train de travailler
là-dessus
il y avait une question sur le centre
des ponts de secours alors effectivement
le centre des ponts de secours a été
transféré depuis le ministère au cerema
depuis le 1er janvier 2021
et globalement ça marche voilà enfin ça
fonctionne assez bien
voilà alors deuxième question sur ces
questions de guichet unique
moi je vous rejoins tout à fait sur le
fait que il peut pas y avoir 36 guichets
uniques pour les collectivités et donc
que le guichet unique c'est préfet sous
préfet ça me semble assez évident
simplement
préfet sous préfet pardonnez-moi mise à
part quelques personnes quelques
individualités par construction un
préfet ou un sous-préfet ça n'a pas de
culture technique et donc
oui oui mais le maire si le maire
s'adresse aux sous-préfet pour se faire
conseiller sur un sujet technique voilà
donc non mais si il faut qu'il s'adresse
aux sous-préfet simplement il faut d'une
part voilà il faut qu'on mette en place
auprès de la préfectorale des équipes
qui soient capables de conseiller
techniquement les élus accessoirement il
faut aussi former les préfets et les
sous préfets mais bon là je m'avance sur
un sujet mais en tout cas le point
d'entrée nous vous rejoignons à 100% ça
ne peut être que préfet ou préfet par
contre ça veut dire qu'il faut organiser
l'État en fonction pour que ça
fonctionne comme ça excusez-moi monsieur
le
directeur si vous permettez mais comme
nous sommes peu nombreux nous nous
permettons voilà un échange peut-être
moins formel la semaine dernière dans
cette même salle avec mon collègue Rémi
Cointreau qui est le premier
vice-président nous avons beaucoup parlé
de simplification et nous avons
enfin quand je dis nous le Sénat et le
gouvernement ont signé une charte
d'engagement sur la simplification
notre dossier portait essentiellement
sur ce qu'on appelle la fabrique de la
loi à venir et un procès en quelque
sorte comme un process industriel qui
sécurise la qualité de la loi et là je
pense Monsieur le Directeur que dans la
simplification
au-delà de la fabrique de la loi il y a
la simplification qui relève du réflexe
pour les élus locaux un élu local c'est
un généraliste une encyclopédie qui
parfois se dit ignorante c'est-à-dire
le maire il n'a pas d'expertise il n'a
pas d'expertise technique il s'est juste
identifier qu'à un moment il y a un
sujet qui relève de son champ de
compétences et quand je dis que le
guichet unique doit être la
sous-préfecture et la préfecture c'est
que le préfet puisse comme le maire l'a
compris qui est un vrai sujet où il y a
un sujet technique et qui l'interpelle
directement
ceux qui ont l'expertise c'est à dire le
le céréma ou d'autres il ne faut pas non
plus qu'on ait ce n'est pas ce que vous
avez dit mais je me permets de le
reformuler il ne faut pas qu'on ait au
niveau de la préfecture de l'expertise
et ensuite le CM1 la préfecture
sous-préfecture pour reprendre ce
qu'elle est dire ma collègue Nadine
belrot et que je lui emprunte pardon
c'est une sorte de garde de triage on a
identifié et donc c'est un front office
qui derrière va aller chercher la
ressource qui va permettre de venir
accompagner le maire mais je pense que
voilà je n'ai pas voulu déformer votre
propos Monsieur le Directeur
non mais je vous je vous rejoins tout à
fait là dessus c'est un petit peu ce que
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
qu'il fallait un minimum de compétences
techniques en département ne serait-ce
que pour pouvoir faire ça mais je vous
rejoins tout à fait sur ce côté gare de
triage sur la simplification
juste vous raconter une anecdote et je
trouve que j'ai été pendant longtemps
directement de l'eau entre 2000 et 2002
et 2008
la loi sur l'eau enfin la réglementation
sur l'eau et d'une complexité
épouvantable enfin voilà c'est clair et
j'avais à un moment on avait essayé de
lancer une démarche de simplification
parce que tout le monde le dit c'est
tout le monde le disait et en réalité ce
qui est au café des groupes de travail
des machins des trucs dans tous les sens
et en vérité ce qui est remonté était
plus compliqué que ce qui existait déjà
et pourquoi ça parce que moi j'en ai
tiré quand même une conclusion c'est
pourquoi nous avons en France un
dispositif réglementaire enfin qui est
d'une complexité épouvantable enfin
franchement en fait parce que on est
dans un pays très cartésien et qu'on
veut que la loi traite ou le règlement
tous les cas tous les cas
et
bah du coup évidemment à chaque ne vous
trompez pas derrière chacune des lignes
si je prends l'eau que je connais bien
derrière chacune des lignes du code de
l'environnement consacré à l'eau il y a
quelqu'un qui a fait en sorte que cette
ligne soit mis pour protéger telle ou
telle intérêt pas forcément et donc
simplifier c'est très compliqué parce
que ça veut dire qu'il va falloir à un
moment
donner beaucoup plus de pouvoir
d'appréciation à l'administration d'une
part et au juge d'autre part parce que
le deuxième élément qu'il faut quand
même avoir en tête c'est que quasiment
tous ces sujets là qui touchent les gens
au cœur de leur vie fini chez le juge
on peut aller plus loin titre personnel
j'ai quelques théories sur le sujet qui
dit qu'en fait si on veut simplifier il
faut probablement y compris changer le
système de juridiction administrative
mais bon
ça pose un tas de questions mais en tout
cas de vous trompez pas sur la
simplification derrière chaque règle
derrière chacune des je sais pas combien
de millions de lits il y a toujours il y
a toujours quelqu'un à qui ça bénéficie
entre guillemets et c'est ça la
difficulté quand vous prenez le droit
anglo-saxon le droit anglo-saxon est
effectivement beaucoup moins fourni mais
parce qu'en fait il laisse beaucoup plus
d'appréciation au juge et ça va
jusqu'aux États-Unis où on est l'idée
juges
c'était pas le sujet je voudrais juste
revenir sur la répartition répartition
géographique des adhésions j'ai envie de
dire ça effectivement ça couvre assez
bien l'ensemble du pays avec quand même
un effet diagonal du vide qu'on retrouve
qu'on retrouve un petit peu partout
on essaiera nous de le compenser
évidemment bon en plus on est au début
des adhésions je veux dire je pense que
le système après va vivre je suis à peu
près certain que dans deux trois ans on
aura 1000 1500 adhérents enfin ça se
fera ça se fera naturellement nous ce
qui nous a quand même vraiment frappé et
déjà en introduction en face ça nous
oblige à assez fortement c'est
effectivement la tente on voit qu'il y a
vraiment un besoin fort une attente très
forte des collectivités ça veut dire que
nous aussi il va falloir qu'on qu'on se
mette en situation de répondre à cette
attente donc c'est des changements
internes aussi qui sont qui sont assez
importants on en est assez largement
conscient on a commencé évidemment
depuis quelques mois à mobiliser les
équipes là dessus mais
évidemment alors c'est le modèle qu'on a
créé donc on y croit et on est surtout
enthousiaste c'est normal mais nous on
est assez persuadé quelque part la
solution elle est dans ce genre de truc
c'est-à-dire qu'il peut pas y avoir les
machins de l'état d'un côté les machins
des collectivités d'autre part on n'est
plus assez riche pour faire ça et la
bonne solution bah c'est bien d'avoir
des des moyens techniques qui soient
effectivement partagé
merci Monsieur le je pense que vous avez
raison je veux dire
je le dirai autrement je veux dire que
la rareté de l'argent qu'on a crise
oblige et nous amène assez naturellement
à être inventif être des solutions quand
on n'a pas de question et de de sujet on
ne va pas aller provoquer des soucis
voilà donc aujourd'hui on est
je dirais naturellement amené à
s'interroger à être efficace et
optimiser la dépense publique parce que
et nous l'avons dit encore hier au
groupe
conduit par le président l'archet moi je
pense qu'on ne cesse de dire qu'il faut
plus d'argent pour accompagner les
services et les collectivités
est quand même temps
nous sommes quand même dans une
situation financière dans notre pays qui
est assez préoccupante et que donc
voilà ça va bien et je pense que la
préoccupation qu'on va voir c'est la
pertinence
de la réponse qu'on apporte aux
collectivités alors ça peut être un peu
compliqué et on doit peut-être
travailler d'une manière plus agile en
réseau et en intelligence d'où la
nécessité
de pondre les collectivités et moi je
crois Monsieur le Directeur
beaucoup dans les leçons que nous avons
appris de la crise sanitaire à un moment
où il y a une situation complexe il y a
beaucoup d'acteurs il faut un chef
d'orchestre
moi je n'ai jamais vu d'orchestre
brillant qui n'ont pas de chef et le
chef il le chef d'orchestre il nous joue
pas du violoncelle elle a pas à la place
du premier prix de violoncelle voilà non
mais il l'harmonise il coordonne et il
fait la pertinence de l'action c'est
pourquoi moi je crois beaucoup au fait
que l'ensemble des
contributions que l'on a au service des
collectivités
doit être organisée de cette manière
c'est à dire comment on est efficace et
pertinent
et après l'organisation elle se plie à
l'exigence d'efficacité que nous
que nous partageons et moi je crois
qu'une organisation elle est jamais
définitive et je vous ai dit l'autre
fois que parfois les organisations ou
les hommes qui les composent ont des
courbatures parce qu'on les amène à se
tordre un peu pour bouger s'organiser
différemment c'est très vrai mais les
courbatures il faut qu'elles servent
l'effort et que
vous avez en même temps raison de
souligner que croire en un miracle qui
ferait que en fusionnant tout le monde
d'un coup tout ça ça va bien marcher non
non je pense que c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça et en même temps
l'inaction parce qu'il y a de la
difficulté
ne doit pas être notre ligne de conduite
en espèces et je sais que ça n'est pas
la vôtre vous vous l'avez démontré
mes chers collègues
je voulais vraiment vous remercier
Monsieur le Directeur de votre
venue ce matin donc à la délégation vous
imaginez bien
c'est pas que nous sommes omniscient
mais nous nous intéressons à tout parce
que nous travaillons
sur les sujets des collectivités ça veut
dire il y a peu de sujets
que nous ignorons et que je suis
particulièrement contente même si on
peut regretter que ce jour étant ce
qu'il ait beaucoup de nos collègues ont
été empêché mais je suis très contente
qu'on ait cet échange sur le cérémain
encore une fois pour reconnaître votre
expertise le besoin qu'on a de vous et
le fait certainement que si le Sénat est
amené à nouveau à faire des propositions
en matière d'organisation
ce que nous pourrons être amenés à
proposer si nous proposons quelque chose
dans votre champ ça
encore une fois que par la
reconnaissance de votre capacité unique
d'expertise le besoin que l'on a et ce
que nous savons de votre envie de servir
l'intérêt général et les collectivités
donc en aucun cas nos suggestions
réflexions ne saurait être considérées
comme un châtiment
mais au contraire vous savez qui aime
bien châtie bien et nous nous chations
pas mais je pense que voilà il est
important qu'on dialogue de cette
manière très libre très franche pour que
le l'ensemble de nos collègues qui sont
aujourd'hui dans des commissions très
différentes la commission des affaires
sociales la commission des lois la
commission
l'aménagement et du développement
durable la commission culturelle
éducation nous partageions voilà
ensemble cet échange sur un sujet
extrêmement technique mais qui
aujourd'hui est au cœur de nos
préoccupations encore une fois je pense
au trait de côte je pense aux mobilités
et je pense à la sécurité naturellement
à l'environnement
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur merci cher